(upbeat music)
- You can't really teach
someone to be a lowrider,
you just live and breathe it.
A lot of people associate
lowriders with the car hoppers,
which is what you see
on TV, or at a car show;
you know, all these cars
who get high off the ground.
And there's the cars like mine,
we just cruise low to the ground.
I like to cruise low and slow.
My name is Ruby Ramirez, and
I'm also known as "Chingona."
I'm a part of the Califas Car Club
and the San Francisco Lowrider Council.
I'm just a girl who loves to lowride.
A lot of people get really surprised,
like, this is your car?
People think the car is my husband's.
No, it's my car.
I wanted my car to say,
I'm a badass bitch.
Chingona means badass bitch.
So, my car is a 1950 Chevy Fleetline.
Originally, it was all
blue, it just wasn't me.
I just drew what I wanted down on paper,
and laid down some patterns,
and with everyone's help we got my vision
from paper to the streets.
And, now it's cruising everywhere.
In the lowrider community
there are very few women.
There's clubs that don't
allow females, and it sucks.
There's some female car clubs out there.
I, myself, don't wanna be
in a all female car club,
because I wanna show that we
can be with the big boys, too.
We shouldn't separate ourselves
because we're already separated.
They have categories that
are female only, and, why?
Why can't we be right there with the guys?
Why can't we compete with the guys?
(upbeat music)
I've heard a lot of people,
oh, you know I've seen you,
and you're an inspiration,
so that's pretty cool.
I wish every woman
could get behind a wheel
and experience cruising a lowrider.
There's a lot of women out
there that wanna be a part
of this, and either they don't know how,
or they just don't have
someone to give 'em a kick.
So, hopefully, they see me,
and we can continue to bring
this into the future.
(upbeat music)